hello I'm Conan O'Brien welcome to
serious jibber-jabber and I am sitting
here with one of the funniest men on the
planet Earth
ever let me amend that looking funny
looking one of the funniest looking
looking man ever mr. Mel Brooks he's
written and directed numerous classic
comedy films including the producers
Blazing Saddles and Young Frankenstein
he single-handedly changed Broadway with
the theater production of the producers
and he co-created one of my all-time
favorite television shows Get Smart Mel
this is a dream for me thanks for being
here
wake up wake up now yeah wake up now
this is you know you're a pleasure
you're easy I want to apologize for for
coming on your show with my white jacket
they don't like that on television my
black shirt my white jacket bring you
out my own folding chair uh-huh and
being on the right you're not used to
you settling but I loved it it was
different I love it when someone changes
it up you came out I said Ron I'm sorry
if and you said I don't want to sit on
this side I always have to sit on that
somebody to a talk show and you sat on
that side yeah and it made me use a
different part of my brain yeah it has
never been used
I don't think since childhood but you
know it was nice about that night is we
get a young audience
you walk out standing ovations amazing
amazing is now not amazing I I knew that
you know what happened yeah but your
work and what you've done
endures you have these kids that they
don't know so much they don't know who
Jimmy Carter is they love your work
that's how the times it it's very nice I
go into like I don't know a young young
area like the mall and you know the
Promenade in Santa Monica and it'd be a
bunch of young kids and they sometimes
they scream
spaceball rules honey you know is that
it's it's very nice you know Spaceballs
my son Beckett who's seven loves Star
Wars and I showed him Spaceballs I'm you
could cry
and in he never stopped laughing at the
Rick Moranis giant Darth Vader helmet
which is a sight gag that works every
time
I mean I'm an adult Rick leaves frame
I've seen it I've laughed he comes back
in with the helmet I'm laughing again
it's such a stupid idea and it's so
brilliant was it was a funny big dumb
funny idea and it worked it was it was
kid stuff let me ask you uh you know
it's you you when you for when you come
on the show we were talking a little bit
about growing up in Brooklyn and we
didn't get to talk about this but when
you were a kid I've heard that you
fought comedy was Jewish I did you
thought comedy was Jewish you didn't
think a Gentile could be funny I don't
think they got it yeah I thought that
they were
I thought Gentiles were were nice more
or less I mean the whole area that I
grew up in Williamsburg um tenements
Stoops was all full of Jews it was just
Jews everywhere I mean you take a wrong
step you step on a Jew it was really it
was terrible these are things you can
say that I can't say yeah I can't walk
into a rat into a neighborhood and go
Jews everywhere yeah right I get in
trouble you get to say it right but they
spot you but no cuz no to eyes right
here in his tall yeah yeah but you know
and every once in a while some Italians
are Irish is some weird creature you
know would would drift why and and you'd
hear an old Jewish woman say give them
something help them you know because
they were so gentle it was so would they
were so strange
yeah it was they were they were you know
aliens and I was like a unicorn - you
walk through if you saw a Gentile a
strange creature yeah really I mean
Wickenburg was totally Jewish so did you
I grew up one of six kids in an Irish
Catholic family I grew up in the early
years thinking comedy was Irish until I
learned the truth yes is that some of us
are funny
it's mostly the juice ah me there's a
you guys have done well you've done well
between just just between Juno and the
paycock or the Sean O'Casey yeah
just between Beckett and and maybe
Yates's I mean when I discovered that
these were all Irish writers yeah
James Joyce the best [ __ ] writers in
the world and they were not not one of
them was a Jew I just I had a nervous
breakdown
I mean I I cried for about a month you
know yeah I was gonna be stored by um I
don't know when they told me Modigliani
was a choice at all great it's a great
Pedro thank you for that you know it's
my it's like Sandy Koufax
yeah juice no juice you know it's so
silly but they do they know you know
Zero Mostel knew all the all the Jewish
Italian painter's you know he knew he
knew his kind yeah you know it's kind
were funny family what did you come I'm
a naturally funny family I was the
youngest of four um yeah kind of
good-natured my mother my father died
when I was only two my mother raised
four boys I mean if there's a heaven
[ __ ] she got there she raised four
little boys from like two to ten single
mom
yeah single mom my aunt Sadie helped out
a great deal
she brought homework homework you know
like bathing suits ashes and the big
bags of them and my mother would from
about 10:00 at night when she put us
when we were sleeping Tibet she would
reverse with a steel rod I don't know if
this makes any sense
these thin snake like sash satin sashes
that was stitched on the wrong side and
he'd get him on the right side she'd
turn him over turn him over turn and
she'd refill the bags with the correct
stitching hidden
in the bathing suits ashes then said he
would take him back the next day to her
factory where they were used do you know
in the sheet what did you grow up
thinking this is what I'm gonna be doing
this why I knew I always lived in 365
South third Street which is one of the
tenements in Williamsburg and South
Williamsburg North became very chic
recently but I knew I was headed for the
garment center I just knew I was like it
was destiny everybody in those tenements
it was it was it was like a sci-fi movie
we were all robotic lis destined to end
up on 7th Avenue either cutters or
shipping clerks or sometimes salesmen
but we were all heading for the we are
for the garment Center which was the
real industry in New York so how did you
get from you're headed to the garment
industry into show business what when
did you know when did you get the bug
when did you know this is what I have to
do I know comedy it was kind of like a
giant mistake you know that happened we
had in our neighborhood we had a
celebrity we had an actor his name was
dawn Appel he later wrote this too shall
pass a wonderful play about racial
prejudice and he also produced on
television the Vaughn Munro show racing
with a moon you've never heard you're
too young for Vaughn Munro but I'll
catch up
yeah you want to know more about Vaughn
1 Munro you got a look at mom he was he
wasn't a bad singer he wasn't great but
you know but dawn was it but dawn was in
a play on Broadway called native son
with a great actor called Canada Lee who
was a and it was a really it was a
beautiful play and don was one of the
stars Donna bell of native son on
Broadway and he'd come home every night
and a few of us two or three of us would
stay up and wait for him he didn't get
there till 11:30 - you know sometimes
midnight
and we'd be and mr. Shamus that was the
grocery man's milk box waiting for
because we knew he'd show up at the milk
box to tell us what happened that night
if somebody died in the audience of
coughed or whatever yeah and he'd
regaled us with stories of makeup and
backstage and who put out which which
chorus girl you know he would tie he
would tell her you're feds attend to
everything and we were just we were
thrilled and then and with only two of
us Joe Joey Joe commander and me and we
decided that's where we're gone we're
going backstage we're gonna be we're
gonna put on makeup we're gonna we're
gonna entertain well Don Appel was also
in the summertime a social director and
he worked at the Avon Lodge sit Caesar
was one of the musicians he played a
tenor sax right and dawn when they
weren't playing they were kidding around
and Don spotted the the latent nascent
comedy in Sid Caesar and you know
brought him along and anyway he got me a
job at I don't think every every place
in the mountains in the borscht belt on
the mountains or the Catskills was coal
Lodge but I kind of I got me a job he
worked at the Avon Lodge and he got me a
job at the butler Lodge Robo tender
busboy and utility actor in case
somebody died really got very sick if
the guy who's meeting the robo guy yeah
I called it I call the kid is doing the
rowboats so they did once they said you
know the district attorney the guy's
playing you district attorney you know
we were doing a play up etat with large
called Uncle Harry I think it's a
British play and there was a DA Uncle
Harry has killed somebody and the DA
played by Bert Reed a very very good
actor but for somebody he fell in a hole
this is the trophy was walking
he didn't see the hole no but Ellen
really falls into a felon hole look
buddy and he felt how it banged himself
up and he couldn't do the show that
night so they called me now the district
attorney Bert was about I don't know 28
or 30 and the dictator's folks will be
about 70 and I was about 14 and a half
maybe 15 and they said do you think you
could do it I said they're there Harry
please sit down relax have a glass of
water and tell me in your own words what
exactly do you remember I knew every
line in every play that you still know
it every single line Wow never forget so
they said D he knows it he's too young
but the kid he knows it
put him on well he'll need a lot of
makeup well do it do it so they put a
white wig on me they put a mustache they
they they wrinkle they put wrinkles they
put black lines all over I said they
said no no you know no that's
Parkinson's don't all right all right
said I'll do whatever
then I mean he came in how he came in
you know lights are you I entered you
know there's an audience in Wow oh I
said they're there Harry
I think I was talking for those who
delivers have a seat they tell me in
your own words
well you whatever you can remember
everything here have a glass of water it
slipped the water slip fell out of my
hands crashed in front of him on the
desk stub thousand shards hush from the
audience
hush from Harry hutch from me silence in
the middle of his play Mel Brooks walks
down to the footlights takes off his wig
it was buzz is is I'm 14 I've never done
this before I get enormous laughter yeah
enormous of course I think the directors
well you got a half a scissor and was
trying to kill me yeah but I knew then
okay that's it you got that laugh and
that's a chemical reaction that's it it
said you were meant not for the garment
Center but to make people laugh go forth
from this place
Elvin and make people happy make them
laugh and you'll get a lot more money
than their garments something that's the
voice I heard yeah that's a very wise
voice somebody Jew also a Jewish voice
uh you know what's funny to me your
start and show business your first big
laugh is you breaking the fourth wall
yeah and that is something that you did
so brilliantly in several of your movies
breaking the fourth wall and I'm when
you did it in Blazing Saddles it just
broke people's minds in a great way I
mean it really blew people away but it
is always been something that you've
liked to do it was the first laugh you
got and it was something that you had
you kind of dropping the other shoe or
telling the ultimate truth or you know
yeah it works it way it works the
audience knows that that essentially
it's making they know it's make-believe
and you just join them in that a given
points you know and it works
what were you who are you watching who
was funny to you when you were a kid
that's that's a good question I don't
know if I want to answer it at this
point in our relationship okay how about
our awesome good wine I can yeah okay I
give you a little wine maybe yeah but
what about what did you drink with Marty
short just have straight Irish whiskey
no no I don't know we had we had wine we
should have had really ski we should I
was sure we should have had whiskey they
were arrested there were Irish whiskey's
you know are there yeah I don't know
this stuff yeah no one tells me what
kind of wine do you remember the wine
you had Cabernet I think was a Pinot
Noir Pinot Noir
yeah Pinot Noir is a burgundy by the way
just more I have a wine cellar really
would you like some I would I would like
to go live there can I live there hey
that let's do another one of these in
your wine side and we'll just drink and
and I'll sleep therefore let me get back
to the first thing I remembered I think
was Charlie Chaplin yeah at that there
was a place in Coney Island Joe Heller
told me he was born a block away from it
golf Feldman's on surf Avenue and
Feldman's was like
nathan's but a place a restaurant that
you could sit down and have a hamburger
frankfurter or whatever you know was
there Oh oka Rondon and but they had
silent movies so I always begged my mom
not to go to Nathan's but to go to
Feldman so I could see Buster Keaton or
I could see Charlie Chaplin I and
because it was it was so magical when so
thrilling and and all of us really left
I remember the first thing I ever saw
was Charlie Chaplin in a boxing ring
hitting the guy getting behind the
referee in Cairo it's just it was an
amazing thing it was amazing phenomena
amazing performance and I said well
that's it's really comedy that is really
comedy and I never forgot it did you
like the Marx Brothers I love them
because when I see the Marx Brothers
there's something about what they're
doing that always has felt evocative to
me about you which is anarchy anarchy
and relentless yes relentless you are
relentless
you know Chaplin can be measured and
sometimes it's a ballet you you are
relentless in the way that the Marx
Brothers are relentless you don't you
when I was doing history of the world
part one and it was this beautiful
courtesan somebody and I was the King
and she's bending over to pick up flower
I just banged into her I said I said
what I'm doing I'm doing Harpo Marx
without you know he just listened to his
body rhythms if there was a woman around
he was just bang into her you know he'd
great I mean I mean the freedom that
they had the and and the the kind of
vocal ping-pong that he'd play with
Chieko and it was just it was just
absolutely thrilling I also like
the Ritz brothers nobody knows yes the
thing is I don't know the work of the
Ritz brothers they were here about the
Ritz brothers but I don't know their
work were they they were sensationally
they danced in unison perfectly
they sang Harry Ritz well yeah we which
had your first everybody when you watch
Jerry Jerry Lewis yeah Jerry Lewis or
Sid Caesar or countless great physical
comics dare do we keep doing Harry would
like wouldn't take I'll tell you the
truth
it's Harry right Harry rich the center
of the Ritz brothers I used him in
silent movie he went to purchase a suit
the one that was in the window
was a display of the tailor's prowess
with canvas yeah and with paper and what
stitching he bought that soon yeah yet
that would be so great so he did is an
agent would say do it and you know and I
think that humor I think if I may wax
this is for waxing that's what we do
here is why intellectually I think it
comes from hundreds of years of Jewish
humor in villages staples or villages
because I don't think the Jews were
allowed to to to do their stuff in
cities actually but there I think their
comedy was based on misfortune hmm I
think if there was a hunchback or a
[ __ ] he was its grist for the mill
you know how age of us is getting
awkward and the youth they used it and
they got big left they didn't give a
[ __ ] you know that it was in
questionable taste you know so and the
rich Harry Ritz just got it from from
that school of comedy did it not because
the Marx Brothers have lived on because
of the films I mean Duck Soup is a
classic good the Ritz brothers not did
not get through on film or do you think
it did get to is there a reason why
people don't know the
Ritz brothers the way they know the Marx
Brothers you've said profoundly without
realizing cuz you're not that smart but
I was a high sümbül no stumble I stumble
thing right but it is what perpetuates
our feeling about people is their
longevity there's very little or no
longevity if 20th Century Fox doesn't
reissue Sonia any movies yeah in which
the Ritz brothers were the comic relief
you know the comedy relief and roughly a
lot of the Sonia Annie you know Chu she
was she was I know yeah she was like you
know an Olympic star yeah they made
movies with her usually starring John
pain occasionally Don Ameche but the
rich brothers were always the comedy
relief in those pictures you know and
and then if well at least they were in
movies let me tell you a story
may I yeah it'd one of your favorite
people sit Cesar yeah so it's the second
year second year we've done the Admiral
Broadway review we have done the first
year that was 48 to 49 are you write is
this I'm writing you're writing for Sid
I'm writing I was his Stooges yeah
yelling yelling ideas and jokes and then
formally writing the first year of the
show of shows a bit of a genius
by the name of Pat Weaver worked at NBC
and he thought of this two and a half
hour evening of comedy Jack Carter with
one hour from 8 to 9 from Chicago and
Sid Caesar at the international theater
in Columbus Circle for an hour and a
half under the leadership of max Liebman
nuprin literally put on a Broadway revue
did nicely-nicely even knew him from the
Army didn't he didn't he found him in
tars and spars yeah yeah in the Coast
Guard but after max Liebman found him in
the Coast Guard and used him you know
immediately on his show
knew he had a big time right yeah so
anyway Sid I met I met said because of
Donna Bell there again Donna Bell
brought me to the Copacabana because
he said you know one of the guys and my
shows in the mountains as has made it as
a comic so I said oh Sid Caesar I saw
tars and spars so he introduced me to
sin we hit it off and I I entertained
Sid and after his stint at the
Copacabana he worked at the Roxy theater
and he said I mean I'm the stage show
I'm the comic relief in the stage show
the movie is forever amber it'll
probably be there a couple of weeks it
was there for close to a year
I really never stopped running so he
would go crazy and he'd call me and say
come and I'd come backstage before you
know and while the movie was playing and
I would entertain sin dokdo and then he
told me about this television show and I
said I'm not sure graven images I'm not
sure yeah my take your picture where's
it going it's out there like a Native
American I said you know he's very funny
I said it's going to the netherworld he
said Holland I said no ha ha ha so
anyway we I began writing yeah is this
is to your point believe it and I'll be
getting you back that's all right and
Admiral broader review 1 season 39 in
those days we wrote 39 shows second year
this this genius Pat Weaver they The
Jakarta Show didn't work but we do still
an hour and a half from 9:00 to 10:30
out of New York NBC and big ratings big
hit second year even bigger ratings even
bigger hit against Milton Berle against
wrestling against whatever was right on
television in those days okay it's time
for Sid Caesar to sign for this third
year probably for two years and maybe
three three years right
so genius I say said don't sign do not
sign I had done a couple of months
trying to figure out something with
Freddie Coleman and these these guys at
Columbia I was going to write a movie
for them called PAL Joey
they'd family from the
and I was talked up as being this new
smart funny writing kid so I was only in
in my late 20s so they took me out to
the coast and I worked there for three
months during the summer and a Sinatra
could not at that point do PAL Joey so
it all went for naught but still they
paid me and we talked about movies and
one of the guys mentioned you know
you're writing the city because they
knew I was going back to writing it they
said why don't you bring him out here
we'll make some movies with him this guy
Jerry Wald was running he was a very
good comedy writer when he was a kid
running the movie production at Columbia
Pictures so I came back and I said Sid
don't sign let's go
Dollywood let's make movies I'll direct
them I'm very smart
I can do that and we'll get writers with
me and we'll write you're funnier than
Danny J I said he's he's fine he's
charming yes he's delicious he's really
entertaining but he's not funny right
you are really funny you're funnier than
Red Skelton you're funnier than anybody
in Hollywood and you know you'll be a
revelation to the world and the world
you know they only know you on
television and the you know and crazy
about you but you go whenever you go to
sweeten wouldn't you like to be seen and
swim so anyway I said more important
Sydney call him Sydney when I was
serious
Sydney if you make movies you will live
it'll you know like Voltaire wrote
things down and we read them to this day
on celluloid you will live on kinescope
you will die kill difficult the workload
yes of 39 right 39 shows yeah doing five
or six different you're easy and
everything isn't everything so he said
you're right let's do that come on now
let's go to Hollywood let's make movies
he was handsome I said you'll be a
eating man and you'll be the funniest
leading man that ever lived and we'll
take our time and we'll do a movie a
year and we'll both get rich and we'll
you know we'll meet beautiful women and
we'll live under a palm tree it's
gorgeous out there and he said okay and
he he did say he said I will do that I
will do that and he spoke to max Liebman
and of course there was panic and went
all the way to the top of of RCA you
know the Sarnoff people ran and they
could all went crazy and at the end of
the week I said said I haven't heard
from you you know what's going on I call
Jerry Wald I call Freddie comb are
called Joanie taps Joanie taps one of
the producers wore black and white shoes
I never forgot it black and white wing
tip shoes nobody watched I said I said
Joanie not since the 20s nobody is where
you know that's one anyway I said Sid
we're going to Hollywood you know and I
said but you know I call I said I
haven't I haven't heard from you and Sid
said they were they were giving him
something like five in those days now
I'm talking about
let's see 49 50 50 51 51 50 job talking
about 1952 in 1952 he would be making
$5,000 a week that's like a million I
don't know what I don't really know you
know yeah you know what them what they
yeah but was a lot it was a lot of money
but I'm sure they backed up the truck
was that it then yes so and they did
very well NBC it was their star program
and so what they what they did is they
he said he kept saying no no no they
said we'll double it he said no I'm
gonna make movies because I said in the
end you'll make just as much money maybe
more but you'll have what we all want we
want we don't want fame and fortune we
want our stuff to be seen in a pre we
want to be appreciated that's what we're
living for
in in this business well we want to be
we want to be saluted by the world for
for our contribution to to show but so
in the end they offered him twenty five
thousand a week and he couldn't say no
so that was the end of our dreams and to
this day I will walk because of my
movies I will walk somewhere and kids
will shout spaceball rules yep
but if Sid walked anywhere they wouldn't
pay any attention to its it they don't
know what he's done it's just like you
don't know the Ritz brothers right this
greatest comic that ever lived is
unknown in America today you know it's
funny because I don't know whose idea it
was but I one of the reasons that I
really wanted to get that I was inspired
I remembered very clearly the movie
theater called the hearthstone Plaza
right near my parents house in Brookline
and my dad took me to see sometime in
the early 70s they packaged your show of
shows Oh ten four ten ten ten from your
show of shows and they showed it and I
went and watch that in the movie you've
never seen him before never seen how
could because I couldn't no Sid Caesar
was they weren't rerunning him on TV it
wasn't uh I watched that with my dad and
I remember very clearly that this is
your life sketch
we're SIDS running away in the audience
I watched that and I had that feeling of
how do you get to do that yeah and this
is I don't know 1974 yeah yeah I don't
know I'm 10 11 yeah and that's also not
what I was supposed to like I know a kid
do any for the garments exactly it's
gonna be that's gonna be the first
Gentile in the very center right with
orange hair and freckles but I I saw
that so fortunately that's what kept
that's what brought Sid Caesar to me and
you know I knew who you were through the
movies yeah sure I didn't know a famous
I came what I wanted to see you to
become well known and appreciated for
his singular and really creative
contribution to comedy yeah yeah and and
it never worked it never worked out ruin
so really brings him out - yeah it did
hey I mean I mean he he was up until
1960 I mean you know he did like honors
over nine years on television and then
he went right from that to a Broadway
show like my Manhattan yeah and then
right into mad mad mad mad mad mad world
and then I think he just was he he was
exhausted he was interested I grabbed
him and used him in one or two I in
silent movie yeah I made him the studio
chief I gave him two cigars yeah yeah at
the same time and I let him do all the
crazy takes and all the stuff that it's
it's easier is so well known for and in
history of the world
he was a cave man and he made a
beautiful painting on a cave wall and
another cave man who was the critic the
art critic comes in pees on it you know
pisses horn he's so unhappy and then so
but I used him as much as I could
yeah you know you know within the limits
of what characters we had created to do
these whatever classes after Caesars
hour I'm not enough sure what year this
is
there's gotta be late 50s you were broke
yeah I was no I had done after I'd done
that well I'll tell you when I was broke
uh I struggled through and got a guy
after Caesars hour I was broke and I
struggled for a couple of years why were
you broke were you spending it as soon
as it came in no I this is an
intervention by the way yeah we got to
stop your spending yes insane it's
really you know this shows a lot better
for me than your show I'll do your show
again I promised you when you did my AFR
you were very good oh thank you really
funny you know what I worry about with
that I wanted I was a moat I was
emotional I just wanted to be sweet and
talk about how much you meant to me and
I saw everyone else going out and doing
and doing and doing shtick and kind of
was a rose yeah it was a girl and I'm
backstage and I thought I don't I can't
do it I don't I don't have I don't I
don't feel like that's my place so I
went out and I was nice and then I
walked offstage and I thought oh you
were funny
I'm not zinging him well I always walk
upstage depressed yeah well I don't like
I mean that's what helped I claim you
cuz ha ha ha that's the time they're
spot on yeah
no seriously yeah you know do comics of
jerk rule on yeah no no but uh you are
really I gotta tell you I've seen a lot
of comics I've been around a long time
from from my clubs to borscht belt to
Act two big stuff to television to
movies and stuff and you're up you're up
there you're good you're really good you
know it's interesting i i have lived off
my insecurities as a comedian and i
think there's a lot of it comedians that
do that and for me it's always i never
feel safe and it's so it's my
backpedaling my bobbing and weaving that
seems to that people seem to like and
living when i look at you i don't get
insecurity when I look at your comedy
I've never there's never been a hint of
insecurity coming from your calm is that
fair it's you it is I've never shown it
and but I mean there is an enormous
amount of anxiety behind it but I'm a
brilliant and skilled performer and
actor it's true yeah I cover it with a
great deal of bravado yes you know I do
I'd say you know I like I used to come
on stage in the borscht belt
I'd come on stage and I'd say stop
examining me to dissin to the Jewish
women down front they're looking at I
said well I said stop examining me stop
looking at me relax sit back you're
gonna love me I'm terrific I'm really
funny not like the [ __ ] you've seen
up here me you know you're gonna love
all the stuff I did I went to a
restaurant Thursday night this out done
that's how I what a great way to come
out yeah that's just the way I used to
that is the exact
opposite of how I've approached comedy
yeah and you don't choose how you go at
it everyone finds their way but but I
what you just described is is beautiful
to me because it's obviously you were
right it works but it's such an
audacious it is because the audience
terrifies us yeah fuck'em let's give
them a little of their own you know yeah
let's get let's get even with them hate
your face gether scare the [ __ ] out of
the audience you know and I used to do
that well I think the other thing too is
with your with your films audacious is
another word yeah you're you're I mean I
remembered the reaction but you know I
saw Blazing Saddles before I saw the
producers I know that the producers was
first but I was it I was too young to
see the producers I saw Blazing Saddles
and it was a nuclear bomb went off I
mean which must have been fun for you
yeah it was it was just I said when we
were writing it the writer
we had a great writers room there was
Andy Bergman there was Norman Steinberg
there was Richard Pryor said he
mentioned and we all had bagels and lox
for breakfast Richard had Remy Martin
for breakfast anyway I said - I said to
these guys this thing Ilyn is this guy's
just gonna go nowhere it's a Western
people haven't seen a Western in 35
years they don't give a [ __ ] about we're
making a Western they don't give a [ __ ]
about horses letting this is not gonna
work so let's do everything that we
weren't allowed to do as comedy writers
as kids is let's just you know all bets
are off we go nuts and that's the way we
wrote it we wrote it crazy
Richard Pryor I was supposed to play if
you want to yes I I always gotta be the
sheriff he was gonna be black bar yeah
and then somebody from Warner Brothers
said uh he takes drugs we've done we you
know we have people
lawyers we can't there's no insurance he
does and he did he was taking drugs but
but he still was the best yeah what
difference did it make
and I said to them nobody will know
they'll just see a performance and he'll
crane level kill them he's the he's the
best comic that ever lived I said you
know you got a but they wouldn't have
him and later we saw a lot of we saw a
lot of guys auditioning for Black Bart
and I turned to Richard I was at him
next to me I said Richard I love this
guy and he said you know he said
somebody it was Cleavon little yeah and
Richard said you know if I wrote into
town was my kind of tan face of my black
mustache I looked more like a Cuban than
a end and yeah yeah yeah and word n-word
and where it's I look more like a Cuban
in and then he said but this guy he is
[ __ ] black he will scare the [ __ ] out
of them you know and and we also had
charm and grace yes he was beautiful and
his timing was perfect
great timing so we it's like in in in my
making movies I've had a couple of lucky
bad that was a lucky bounce getting not
having Richard Pryor but getting Cleavon
little was a great bounce in favor of of
the movie were really working Blazing
Saddles really working you know my honor
you want him am i on you stay on the
cutting in the middle of my no they
didn't they're gonna cut it beautifully
it'll all be you the the n-word you
could you do that today it felt like
there was a period of time where you you
use that word and it well in Django
quick yeah do you know now yet yes he
used it but who used it more is it more
in Blazing Saddles or is it more in
Changa it's about even you counted right
it's dreadful yeah
yeah it's arable yeah but both in a good
cause
yeah I don't think anybody uh my son Max
was explaining the guy that did in a
world war zero to max was explaining to
me the other night he said and he said
you know dad I don't think anybody has
covered slavery as acutely and as
brilliantly as Tarantino did in Django
he said it's really covered in other
movies
it's sentimentalized it's emotionalized
it's romanticized but he named he said
Quentin nailed slavery just for what it
was yeah it's horrendous and he did it
so and it's a it's a great picture and
you know when I saw him in a restaurant
after it opened I said I forgive you for
taking the n-word from me yeah from
another white man and I said it and I
told him how wonderful I thought his
movie was you know I want to talk about
the producers I know that I didn't see
it till after I'd seen Blazing Saddles
and I loved it and then I was shocked to
find out you made the picture and it's a
classic and then when I you know years
later biggest hit ever on Broadway when
it came out critics killed it is that
true well the the one we needed the most
to survive the initial opening of the
film was the New York Times because that
was like the the posh paper you know the
you know the important paper that would
drive all the Jews and the intellectuals
to buy tickets to see it you know
however renata you don't forget these
things
god bless me Renata Adler was the motion
picture critic for The Times and she
thought it was just a ridiculous
despicable she called black CollegeHumor
she's what the leading man was
fad it's for cr0 maestro busted it he
needed to slim down yeah Troy Zero
Mostel uh and I came home that night
after you know after the Times came out
and and I sat together on the couch and
I was really crying I said well I said I
I was I made a good living in television
get smart mm-hmm show of shows I said I
can go back to it I can make I could
make a living and I can do good things
so movies in you know they don't want me
movies are not for me
and then other papers came out that were
middling warm fair but but then the
magazine's came out look and Time and
Newsweek and there were raves all of
them gene Shalit said no one will be
seated for the first 88 minutes of the
producers they'll all be on the floor
laughing their heads out that's good you
know and so I mean it was just I mean it
was wonderful so he kept it going around
around for about eight eight months it
before sellers take out a he did he
killed me in London he take him took out
of there before we opened and in the
Evening Standard and the the Guardian
big ads double-truck ads right saying
this is the funniest picture ever made
the greatest comedy you'll ever see and
the critic said well you know we'll be
the judge of that
hello and you don't like to hear that so
oh but it hung on in England too and
they liked you know springtime for
Hitler when producers comes out so many
people including yourself
world war ii concentration camps hitler
is so fresh it's still so new did you
have a fear that it's too soon opening
night st. James theater 44th Street on
Broadway opening night of the producers
middle of act 2 we're doing springtime
for Hitler yeah and a big guy stands up
start screaming at the stage and walking
up the aisle where the [ __ ] is Mel
Brooks how dare he such an outrage Jews
and concentration camps and he I'm in
the back and I say I'm out but you know
I want to stop this guy you know it's
the opening night induces and and and he
says I was in I was in World War two and
I said I was in World War two I didn't
see you there I mean I try to defuse
that I was telling no but those well I
got a lot of when I first did the
producers the film rabbis galore I just
got every rapper in New York sent me a
letter think twice before you do another
thing that's a you know it's a think to
you know and I wrote back to every
single letter I got explaining you can't
get on a soapbox with Hitler you've got
to ridicule him to get you got to bring
him down with laughter II there's no way
to get even yeah and try to make them
understand you know what what the into
the real intent of the springtime for
Hitler number was all about you talk
about lucky bounces I mean gene Wilder
Zero Mostel but then dick Shawn Oh dick
Shawn is someone who I mean I knew I was
the wrong generation yeah yeah you you I
but I a little baby I was a baby but but
I always knew dick Shawn was hilariously
funny he was so and he's so fantastic in
that movie yeah he is so great yeah I
miss him a lot he died at a very young
age died on stage he died on stage yeah
Wow
it's a good way to go I don't want to go
that way you don't want to go on no you
know I'd rather I'd rather die trying to
get to my bed at 102 and then jump
missing and falling on the floor
yeah and saying Manny man I would have a
guy working for the dome
that's the way that's how I want to go
ah calling for Manny and harden - Manny
will be 95 yeah I'm coming um I thought
I uh
Young Frankenstein did you want to be in
Young Frankenstein was it was the idea
that you would be I was gonna do the
county Mars row yeah the you know the
inspector the police come down her and
gene said I won't do it I'll do the
movie with you I'll write it with you
I'll star in it over if you just promise
one thing and I said what's that Jane he
said that you won't be in it why he said
because you're able to pop you'll able
to open the mask of a guy in armor and
say hi of folks right he said he said
you're always breaking I don't want to
break any fourth walls here right I want
it to be in a strange way a salute to
Mary Shelley and James yes yeah I said I
agree with you it's beautiful that way
and he said I would like we should do it
in black and white I said right and I
said okay well you get that how'd you
get it in black made in black and it was
we just it was crazy because we had this
deal with Columbia studio Kent can't be
happy no we had a deal with Columbia
Pictures to make the movie and just as I
was leaving we all shook hands David
picah Schneider all it well Columbia
guys gonna make the movie we're gonna
make Young Frankenstein for Columbia
Jenkins I I get to the door I'd leave it
just as the way I hold the door from and
I say by the way we're gonna do it in
black and white just the way James Whale
would have and I leave and then I hear
these Jews thundering after me down the
hall wave goes what are you crazy
whatever and they grabbed me they took
me back and he said we're not gonna do a
we had an hour later they said okay well
making a black-and-white but on color
stock
so that we can show it in color in Peru
which just got color and I said no no
because you'll screw me yes you will say
this and then in order to save the
company you'll risk a lawsuit and you
will print everything in color it's got
to be on agra plaque and white thick
film even though it's having trouble
going through the sprockets of it that's
I want to get like it looks beautiful it
is Jerry Hirschfeld it's I mean it like
I said we're talking real it looks like
Casablanca it looks yeah it looks like
one of the great black and it didn't it
now it is one of the great
black-and-white bilities black-and-white
backlighting a halo around the lemon and
the other women and Jean jeans blonde
here yeah yeah you know it was just
beautifully photographed I feel like
there's a second where you open break
the fourth wall uh with Marty well Marty
money was very difficult not to break
the fourth he's Lee I think he thought
he looks right to camera one point and
but it's just the tiniest right tiniest
yeah god he was funny Marty Marty was
very brave and he said uh at one point
he said he says I've got this speech
when you mind if I
I don't uh I took some pauses in it I'd
like to take a bit of time when I said
sure - did he - it any way you feel you
know properly comfortable so I said I'll
never forget oh it's that the scenes
thoughts with Gene Wilder and he says
reputation reputation and Terry goes as
dr. you dr. Frankenstein you haven't
touched your food you'll get you you'll
get sick
he said there there and any smashing
head I've touched it there there and
then Marty says I'll never forget what
my father said on a cake
like this I didn't do any to say
anything everywhere
I mean I was crammed with crazy I'll
never forget what my father said on
occasion and so we all you know we all
waited you know I'm behind a camera way
and and and and gene is the best cuz he
just looks away Hey yeah he knows if he
looks at if he's gonna yeah yeah he took
about a minute I'll never think of my
father in occasions like this and gene
takes to hold man finally Jesus what did
he say you know What did he say
and Marty says get out of the bathroom
give someone else a job he's a big
potato I mean it was like it was like to
me to be like the best scene in the
movie you know yeah just a timing and uh
ah it was so I mean it was a such a
pleasure I well I made movies I needed
my rest I would have I would have
cottage cheese and some sliced peaches
or something in my trailer and that was
it
you know I wouldn't just to gather my
strength and having to deal with that
but on that picture I found Cloris I
found Madelyn I found Jeanne I found
Marty Peter Boyle and I would just
gathered them together and have lunch
with them I loved them so literally
loved them so much
let me ask you I don't I don't I was
thinking about this today I don't know
of a comedy mind that's been better at
finding women funny women than you and
you said just now you know there's
Madeline Kahn Bernadette Peters Cloris
Leachman Teri Garr you found such great
funny women I think better you're you're
better at that than than anybody you
know in the history of the medium why
what was it about was hoping against
hope they'd sleep with me
hahahaha alright I know you were
thinking of George Brent I know you
think of a handsome guy with a must
he was an actor a handsome guy with a
mustache but you know who knows it's in
the dark we'll do it fast
yeah and they said no well let's think
about it you know but anyway no I knew
you know did this day I know who who
these people are you know and their day
you know like Sarah Silverman you know
yeah they're talented you know and
there's there's an inner energy and a
glow that you know and Madeline was
Madeline was supremely talented yes and
she could sing as well as any color
coloratura
she sang you know glitter glitter and be
gay which is an aria from Candide that
Leonard Bernstein wrote and it's uh it's
impossible to sing very few people can
sing it and Madeleine could sing it in
the center of every single note with
incredible changes of tempo and she
could do it Madeleine was in and our
timing he was so talented I mean she had
lived one line for me and I nearly
ruined the take because Gregory Hines is
pouring her wine yeah and he says and
she's the Empress in room and as He
pours it he says say when she says 8:30
and ha ha ha it was you know we had
another you know yeah I'm clan but she
just so quickly undercut it Evers she
was amazing but it's funny cuz people
think of that era that sometimes people
think women are allowed to be funny now
there's more of a modern and you think
nuts really not true you always
throughout your career finding really
funny women and letting them carry the
bill really letting them go yeah Cloris
was you couldn't if you have smoked
around Cloris she'd slapped a cigarette
right out of your mouth she was a little
nuts yeah she's still with us thank God
but you know but I'm careful not to
smoke don't smoke around her I wouldn't
that to happen high anxiety high anxiety
you it's an homage to Hitchcock what I
didn't realize is that you actually knew
Hitchcock and you were you were friends
he helped me write it I didn't know I
said them are a very rough outline a
Bracy of it I said it's basically um
your career and I want to know where
when not when and how I'm stepping over
the line and what I'm doing if anything
offends you right yeah if the whole
thing offends you I won't do it because
I admire you so much and I think I said
frankly I think you're the best director
that ever lived and I believe that to
the state he's the best film director
than ever I told that to Billy Wilder
who didn't like that
Billy Watt it yeah that's it they didn't
like that too much but Hitchcock had it
all and I said and he and he called me
and he said mr. Brooks I said who says
he said it's hitch
I said well stop this [ __ ] come on
who the [ __ ] is there you know I said
it's Alfred Hitchcock I said really he
said yes
I want you to come to my studio tomorrow
Friday company Universal I'll leave a
pass for you be there at noon I said yes
sir yes sir you know and I did and then
we tell you talked about the script and
he said what he thought I should use the
parts of his films that he thought would
lend themselves to parody to satire was
he was he right was he he was absolutely
spot-on did he pitch jokes he pitched
one joke I couldn't use it then he
pitched the joke he said there's a man
running and they're after him with guns
drawn and he's running for his life and
suddenly comes to the end end of the
dock and and the ferry is ten ten feet
away and without Herculean effort he
leaps into the air and makes it on the
ferry but he doesn't know that the
ferries coming in
that's good yeah and I said yeah but do
it I wasn't gonna pay for ferrying iron
did you get to socialize much with him
yeah we went to Jason's we wait that was
just for what's it like what's it like
to eat go to Jason's with Alfred
Hitchcock oh I mean it you can get it on
my my and my box said I have your box oh
yeah I haven't seen that part yet
incredible well I think it since it's in
there where it's a true story but can't
believe it so uh he orders a shrimp
cocktail a sirloin steak two inches
medium-rare asparagus and a baked potato
with sour cream okay first thing that
comes sixth large shrimp with cocktail
sauce we I order filet of sole you know
I'm nervous eating with it yeah yeah I
can't eat much and then he eats a steak
tucks it away beautifully asparagus
you only have plenty of sour cream in
the middle of that big potato and I have
new orders a frappe two yellow balls of
ice cream with chocolate sauce some
grated nuts in the cherry and he eats
that okay that's him they pour him some
coffee
sips the coffee he opens his coat
reaches into his best takes out a
beautiful ostrich leather covered cigar
case
flips it open he takes out of probably a
Cuban cigar illegal but he had best
tasted and he puts it in and he takes
out from his vest a little guillotine
and he Clips the tip of the cigar he
reaches in his other pocket and before
he can George the head waiter is over
with a lighter or a match or something
right and he starts Lee leans forward
and stops I said well this is this is a
momentous moment he stops he doesn't
take leans back because stands there
he says George I still feel a bit
peckish do it again
Oh what does he really mean do it again
yeah and five minutes later shrimp
cocktail six large shrimp cocktail sauce
that's arrogance in its own little dish
steak little green things on in in the
in the in the sour cream and then all
these years later you know every detail
of this meal I know every detail
he didn't I lied when I was on
television I said two yellow balls he
didn't I mean he didn't have the dessert
yeah he said I'm going to a shoe
whatever the [ __ ] that I'm gonna wish
you the frappe and the and he had a cup
of coffee and then he lit the cigar I
mean but he had the whole meal I mean he
was and he said to me Melvin he called
Melvin he said Melvin we only live once
and I you know I never forgot that
and that's why once in a while I'll go
to a bar and say what are you doing
later Fido all right all right all right
all right I'll take because he said
don't even wanna go you only live once
here you take a shot you know and you're
embarrassed I'd say now if you don't
show this my children but might be
watching oh I'd like to ask you about uh
you ask enough I've done to you man I
don't even [ __ ] know when I get paid
for this if anything you have to pick
missus if you have to pay for the right
to be here this cost $75 this ride this
is how we this is how we make this thing
pay I'll give you 50 right now k - the
75 is a bit much how the hell did you
land and bankrupt how did you how did
you get her to marry you
most beautiful woman wanted woman how
did you do that
I you know what I really can't talk much
about it yeah it's too it we were very I
was very lucky to yeah yeah she she
spotted something she'd said one thing
that made her um attracted to me she
said you look like my father and you
talk like my mother it's true a great
head great combination yeah you talk
like my mother and it was and we just we
knew we just knew that we were you know
ya meant each other and it was great for
45 years unbelievable and you know and
it's very hard you know to to to do
without it um one thing I have always
had heart a hard time imagining for you
is the idea of you writing for another
performer because you love to do it so
much that I imagine it would be hard for
you to write for another comedian and
someone told me was it true that you
wrote for Jerry Lewis and I have a hard
time too picturing you writing for Jerry
it was one of the toughest experiences
of my life because after writing the
show of shows such a classy remarkable
very creative of an show very literate
yeah we would you know references
attended one of our jokes our references
were incredible whether the orange to
visibly did foreign movies the audience
has never seen a foreign movie did
Japanese movies Italian movies French
movies German movies but once what in
one of our scenes we do we Sid was in
the in the box so he wouldn't hear and
they closed the door and it was a game
show and he was he was in this no
hearing glass glass closed space and
closed bait so they locked the door and
and call what was it was the house that
he began talking he said in 1918
in America entered World War one and Sid
was moving back and forth and finally
slumped on Carlton but the errand but
the era it was amazing and then finally
he said he said and the last question is
for all the money for this for the for
the $64,000 the last question is uh who
wrote the Opera Faust now I mean you
know this is America where we're doing
it we're doing a show for free and hope
for people in North Carolina you know
and and Abilene you know Texas and Sid
says in kind of a Jewish New York way he
says go know and call suggests Kudo you
got it you know gue know is yeah yeah
yeah of the of the Opera you know and so
and so but but I mean the nerve of us to
assume that enough Americans knew that
gue know had read had written samson and
delilah whatever yet i think that was
the opera but also it you still works a
little bit even if you don't know you
know yes still well call was brilliant
and followed up with shouting goon oh
yeah
after synod said go no you know yes and
covered covered it you did that all was
always so you got to get him to do this
so then your writers jibber-jabber good
said so he said didn't he sink i gotcha
on you she did he'd say it on her show
and then he got an offer from touring
opera company so i think he's gonna go
out on the road yes he did um uh so then
you're working for you're writing for
jerry lewis and it's not the same
situation Joe I'd I wrote it I was
writing part of one of the writers of a
movie called the ladies man when I wrote
a couple a couple of jokes that were
okay but he kept he kept improving them
and I kept explaining that's not what
the joke is about or that's not what the
rhythm
about let's or you know and finally I
just quit you know yeah in the middle I
just I know we have a contract don't
really keep the money room you know not
the entitlement for you this and I liked
him I like Jerry Jerry was Jerry was
always good always but but he got is we
all have our own like you do with your
writers and you do it we all have our
own prejudices about what we think works
and what what with a where the rimshot
is you know and yeah Jerry heard the rim
shot somewhere else and you know he
wasn't a bad guy he had a 59 Jaguar
black with leather interior red leather
what a car what a car and he said I
don't like it I know I don't like the
way to handle that him I said Terry it
was beautiful car in the world and this
is Jerry Louie and he had paid 10,000 or
12,000 for it a year before this was
1960 you need was a 59 Jaguar you know X
something kind of beautiful he said you
wanted I said yeah he said give me five
grand I said okay take it out of my
salary you know and I got the car when
I'd where's the car now I gave it away
Morris a couple of years later three or
four years later because I went back to
New York and how we came out here to
doomed to wrecked move yes yeah and you
know and and I really beautiful car so
Jerry wasn't such a bad guy but we
didn't we didn't see eye to eye on
everything that you know he had his own
and he wasn't so so damn bad he was a
bit of a genius in his own oh yeah
world you know he was the French weren't
crazy when they lauded him and what went
nuts about a me they saw a bit of a
genius
yeah right you know night I loved him
personally but I mean we just didn't see
eye to eye on on rhythm was for rhythm
you were a drummer and I know Johnny
Carson was a drummer Johnny Carson was a
drummer and he wasn't so bad
no and I I've actually I think I saw 60
minutes with Johnny Carson where he's
playing you could to you took it
seriously
oh yeah you
you were serious drummer well I mean
four to three years that's how I made a
living you know yeah there was a band
called Charlie Spivak he's a famous band
and his drummer got sick and I was 15 I
too young to be in the Union or
something and I and I subbed for his
drummer for a whole summer at the
Riviera my club at Fort Lee New Jersey
but this was the tempo you know that was
his he played he was known as he was a
trumpet player and he was noted the
sweetest trumpet this side of heaven and
he was very good in the bandwidth was
very good but a little but we would call
musicians would call Mickey Mouse and I
was interested in yeah yeah you know you
know you want to when you drum either
gonna be a dwarf you know so because I
used to I grew up watching you go on
Johnny and I could see how much he loved
you how much you loved being there and
you do feel like you're watching two
drummers it's two guys who know the
rhythm of how something supposed to go
which is a you know and he would you
know he cracked up he'd fall down you
were pretty good when I was on your show
I was I really appreciated your truly
you know enjoying getting cracking up it
was it was very good but it's fun to
watch uh you know I did something I did
some project for Turner where I looked
at a lot of the Johnny Carson's and it
was a real highlight when you would go
on I don't know how it how it felt to
you oh really but throughout the years
it really was appointment television
when you were going to be on The Tonight
Show with Johnny Carson that was that
was a huge deal it well you know is for
me it was it was a genuine you know
thrill it was a genuine thrill because
he and he'd have great retorts he'd come
back the vocal ping-pong was fabulous
yeah you know and I'd always pick up the
wrong I'd make a point of picking up ed
McMahon's mug you know what's in this
you know always every time I was on hey
yeah but works every time
Carson would go go every time we have I
don't want to frighten you with this
device this is a modern device and I
think we have a to questions from the
web is that right Frank all right Sarah
from facebook asks why hasn't Blazing
Saddles been made into a Broadway
musical um Sarah to answer your question
I have not ignored it I've been thinking
about it and I have already kind of
dummied one or two songs that might work
in it and I'm thinking about it and one
of the things that holds me back a
little bit as I'm thinking is he gonna
make a musical edit every movie he made
it's too much you know but who is that
that's who's that voice who's that voice
in your head that's a tiny woman in the
Bronx a woman who's in the Bronx is he
gonna make up opiate enough enough you
know this is woman been in your head a
long time she's always there yeah she
seems comfortable in there Vincent from
facebook asks what do you think dr.
Frankenstein's lab smelled like that's a
good question well um resuscitating dead
tissue think about you know it must have
you know it must have stuck a little bit
yeah II you know I would think but
nobody know you know nobody covered not
enough yeah not enough to commence yeah
I have kept you here a long time love
you it's been a pleasure and uh dull
let's be honest both of us would you use
a third half I don't see us losing any
of this well what you know you don't see
a sue because it's what is it it's the
web right it's the web this goes out
yeah and you know Chick Webb was a
drummer yes I did you did really my
Chick Webb yeah good for you
I'm proud proud uh well you know I
started out trying to be a drummer
really and then I switched over I had I
didn't have much money and I bought a
drum kit
my parents let me buy this drum kit and
it was such a bad drum kit I've never
met a drummer who knows that
manufacturer who was called courtly co
arty I've never heard of court no
drummer no drummer has heard of courtly
and I still have the drums I play them
in high school I played him in college
no offense to courtly yeah I don't think
they make drums I think it's a company
that makes an iron lung and then one and
then one day they said let's try drums
and then they did one and they said it
doesn't work yeah and you got that why I
got the court lead and then I switched
to guitar because when I good out to LA
it you still play - I play guitar yeah
I've moved out and I realized you have a
practice I was paying $380 a month in
1985 rent a month and they're not gonna
let me have a drum kit in my apartment
which means you have to rent a rehearsal
space of course I'm not gonna I can't
afford to do that so I went to a pawn
shop bought a $90 guitar that's just
great good got the Mel Bay chord book
and we got myself that's great good for
you well I know Charlie Christian oh
really I was a kid yeah he was funny
Benny Goodman's he was a genius they're
the one I listened to in my car a lot is
Django yeah I listened to you know
Stephane Grappelli and Jagger
well Django playing a gypsy style yeah
with and he has a Belgian chip yeah who
then lost
I mean you lost a couple of things as
gospel fingers yeah Anna fire a circus
fire how do you know that I have to know
a lot you're just a baby I don't know
that stuff do you know about the automat
oh yes there you put a quarter in and
you get a hamster girls nickels nickels
only that's what I was so long ago two
quarter in there's no room for me did
you go to the automat back in the day
yeah all the time we ate at the automat
us Carl Reiner about they don't talk
about the quarterback and infinitum and
love it right you put the nickel in and
then you get a Serena kozhedub you'd
have a lemon meringue piece of lemon
meringue pie horn and Hardart
hornet hornet I'm really proud of you
thing you're really a baby to know about
older than you think
right you don't have any settled I've
had incredible I've read this correctly
lisanne blasted right yeah I'm an old
old man
you probably got Michael Dunn's face you
think yeah every why they probably gave
you haha is surgery you know let me ask
you a personal question it has a heard
of a running board a running board good
yes
yeah it's what God gangsters would stand
on the side of the running board and
shoot the machine gun where was the
runny boat on what the running board was
on like a hacker would ever run yeah
yeah yeah and it would have a big
running board board I've no ever
that's pretty got a plan but here's
anything about me running board here's
the thing about me I don't know what I'm
supposed to know now I'm from another
era
I'm from the wrong time you are you I
grew up on Jimmy Cagney image with her I
don't wanna I don't want to worry you
but there were occasions during our
interview here that I saw through you to
the back wall and what did you know I
don't know B so you have you may have
some stuff running through you at times
mm-hmm that that is good a good or bad
depending but I did see the wall behind
you saw me disappear for a moment no you
were there but I saw the wall right for
you they got one of your men who as soon
as you do okay uh this is like I want a
contest this is an absolute joy it is an
honor I love you you've been a big part
of my life you continued yeah I'm just
you have given so much to people through
your work and it made me so happy I
remember when you came on our show crowd
of people in their 20s I know who was
amazing I jumped to their feet screaming
and then you started to walk out and I
grabbed you and then I turned you around
and I said look at that
that doesn't I don't see that a lot yeah
and you gave me a big kiss on the cheek
and then I thought I can die now I don't
want to die now but I I can I can go so
this has been just a huge not even
Jewish I'm a little Jinyoung you might
be I think I have a Jew you know you
asked did you ask Marty short he never
answered but he never responded you did
yeah yeah I did I did but when I was he
went toward you said tomorrow at Martin
Short I just have one question for you
are you a Jew yeah
he never ended was no and I was waiting
it there
for the whole thing and he never did he
ever answer he never said he was keeping
his cards very good oh you were talking
ordered them he was not the lucky John
elf Dumbo oh man made by Mike you know
later I played a movie in Ireland and we
part of the movie and I would go into
boss a damn - Guinness is for us good
you took the time to learn the language
yeah Jim yeah damn damn two Guinness are
for us yeah ah it was good it's great I
mean I really had a I hope you had a
good time there's a black I had a great
time this was the most fun I've had that
I can risk was easy this was you know
yeah but you know yeah yeah you know let
this man we're gonna let you go but um
I'm gonna hi Carl can get one can Carl
see this when can people see this on
their on their computers uh what is Carl
- Carl does Carl watch things on his
computers he does he's addicted is it
all legal stuff yeah well no you know no
porn new birth week of the 21st whatever
is a what which month thank you this I'm
impatient with him yeah yeah October 21
yes
smiles over 21 that's only about 10 days
really it's a short time what are we
gonna do put this on transfer this to
film no this is it we got it
we should go out right now and we can
get you guys we can get you guys copies
and then yeah I can actually get you a
copy I love it I really would love it
yeah and especially the part about the
automat the rest of it I don't give a
[ __ ]
we're only we're only using the
automatic the automatic the only the
automat is all were using everything
else didn't make my nose a little yeah
yeah
didn't quite whole show business thing
was that's not what people want to hear
from you if you people here Mel Brooks
is talking to Conan they want to hear
coin-operated sandwich dispensers right
and running boards you
everybody new guises on the run a best
person that ever lived now Brooks I love
you guys thank you so much I do love you
yes my god